qui veut des coeurs distribution de
petits coussinets appelé pas à l'espace
jeunes de saint rémy les chevreuse ce
jour là les enfants vont découvrir le
pack board
c'est le premier cap 21 qui a gagné mais
il ne faut pas qu'il dépasse 21
autrement il redescend à 15 3 points
pour un bac dans la cible un point s'il
reste sur la planche en équipe des
variantes sont possibles sportif les
jeunes de saint rémy les chevreuse font
un relais objectif 50.40
oui je crois ses supérieurs il faut
courir mais c'est vers eux que je ne
viens pas de bien loin françois guérin
l'imaginer le peaufine chez lui à saint
rémy les chevreuse tout a commencé avec
un prototype qu'il a lui même fabriqué
mais le premier était avec la même idée
mais avec une une caisse derrière qui
permettait de mettre les bags pour les
transporter c'est quand même très
compliqué c'est lourd c'est pas facile à
fabriquer mais bon l'idée était là un an
de réflexion pour élaborer l'objet final
qui a déjà fait des petits backboard
family backboard adapte backboard happy
days family pour le grand public
adapt pour les ehpad et les handicaps et
happy days pour les entreprises sont nos
marchés principaux pour le moment le
tout est stocké est conditionné au fond
de sa cour bienvenue dans dans la bacb
ordre house plage et 400 backboard qui
viennent d'arriver et donc l'idée c'est
que
maintenant il faut les conditionner les
emballer et c'est moi qui m'occupe à ce
que je vérifie chaque planche une par
une et chaque coussinets aussi un par un
pour avoir une qualité maximale une
qualité 100% saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse
françois guérin s'entoure des artisans
de la commune pour parfaire son jeu
le menuisier conçoit les planches et les
retouches depuis le début du projet il
en est de même pour la couturière
le deuxième objectif c'est des nouveaux
5 quand il a une nouvelle idée et il
vient me voir on réfléchit ensemble et
je dis coûté non ça va pas ça c'est pas
comme ça où
et au niveau couture je suis
intransigeante sur sur les aspects que
je vois il faut que ce soit parfait avec
trois backboard à son actif françois
guérin ne compte pas en rester là
son but développer cette entreprise pour
ensuite la cedh est un jeune ou une
personne en recherche d'emploi